- Charles Sobhraj a purgé 20 ans
de sa condamnation à vie dansKau
au Népal.
Citoyen français d'origine
vietnamienne et indienne,cococor
le monde au début des années
1970, commettant ici et là
des petits délits. En 1975, il e
dans la tatatale thaïlandaise,
Bangkok, avec son amie
ca
rencontrée quelques moisplplplu.
Se faisant passer pour
précieuses, il se liait d'amitié
avec ses victimes, souvent
des routards occidentaux sur
la piste
1970, avant de les droguer, de
les voler et de les assassiner.
L'habileté du tueur
à disparaître lui vaut d'être
surnommé "le Serpent". Ce serane
la BBC consacrera à S
avant d'être diffusée
le criminel étant incarné par
l'acteur français Tahar Rahim.
- Les amis sont toujours
le
- La série est basée sur
le livre de journalistes
australiens qui le décriventd dt
en même temps fascinant.
Il méprisait ses victimes
qui lui vouaient une confiance
en héros criminel.
(bruit de la circulation
Le couple est arrêté en Inde
en 1976 où il sera condamnéitit.
Le sort de sa compagne
Marie-Andrée Leclerc a retenu
l'attention de tout le Québec.
Alain Stanké l'a interviewée.
ALAIN STANKÉ, journaliste
- Moi, je pense qu'il n'y a pas
complice, mais complice,
elle a tout le temps nié ça.
Mais comment peut-on vivre comme
passait dans l'appartement,
elle vivait avec lui,
sans se rendre comptededededede?
C'est presque pas croy
- Atteinte d'un cancer,
chez elle en 1983.
MARIE-ANDRÉE LECLERC,
compagne de Charles Sobhraj
- Je vivrai ça comme
comme j'ai vécu la condamnation
à vie lninininininière, ce sera
encore une épreuve. Ça l'est,
en fait. Ce que je vis, , , , ,.
Dans un an, je serai peut-être
dans ma tombe.
- Marie-Andrée Leclerc
Sobhraj est libéré en 1997,pupl
en 2003, où il sera condamné
à nouveau pour le meurtrenenenee
en 1975 dans ce pays.
Tant d'années plus tard,
l'histoire fascine encore.eeeeee
de personnages-là q
deux visages, qui ont deux vies.
- Le Serpent doit
du coeur. Il sera expulsé
du Népal dans les 15 jours.
Jean-Michel Leprinc